foreign
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar predicting tracking and
controlling diseases and epidemics to
prevent new epidemics and pandemics that
can be Amplified by climate change I'm
Susie Valdez of lab roots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and brought to you by Abid to
learn more visit them at abbott.com
now this webinar is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits after the webinar
and we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation I'd now like to welcome our
speakers Dr Mary Rogers principal
research scientist at Abbott and
Professor Tulio de Oliveira director at
the center for epidemic response and
innovation in South Africa Dr Rogers and
Professor Dave Oliveira welcome to both
of you Dr Rogers you may now begin your
presentation
looking forward to telling you about the
work that Julie and I are doing as part
of the Coalition so with that I'll get
started
so I'd like to start by giving some
context for
um first we'll start with disclosures
actually so I want to make note that
support for this program is provided by
Abbott I'm presenting a we're both
presenting at the request of Abbott and
the information contained in this
presentation is from the speakers it
does not represent newer implied product
or regulatory claims of the products by
Abbott
so to give you a little bit of context
for the work we're going to be talking
about today I want to share that we are
looking at how viruses mutate and how
that may impact the detection of viruses
um as we have diagnostic tests developed
against them whether those are serology
tests or molecular tests so in the case
of serology tests if the virus has
mutated that could impact our ability to
detect either the antigen or the
antibody and of course if there's
mutations that are in the Target region
of a molecular test those could be
impacted as well as a virus is mutating
in fact if we look at the viral
diversity of two of the viruses that we
make diagnostic tests for HIV and SARS
Cove 2 and we plot them on a
phylogenetic tree we can see there's a
difference in the level of diversity
between these two viruses in fact at the
same scale
the SARS Cove II phylogenetic tree is
just this the period at the end of a
sentence whereas in comparison the HIV
tree is much more diverse and has a lot
of different sequences represented in it
and that's because the number of
mutations that separate these different
strains differ between the viruses so if
we want to make a test in a conserved
region of SARS Cove 2 that's less prone
to mutation that's a lot more
straightforward than making a test that
is targeting a region of HIV that could
be the same in every strain so knowing
about the sequences helps us to design
those tests to mitigate the impact of
viral diversity
and we've been doing this work for
decades in fact we began in 1994 when we
started doing a viral surveillance
program here at Abbott and we've been
primarily focused at the beginning of
the program on HIV because it's so
diverse
since then we've gone on to add new
viruses Hepatitis B C and Delta because
those viruses also mutate frequently and
can change and potentially impact tests
so over the course of the program we've
collected over 100 000 samples and
published over 150 papers describing the
work we've done in the program
we've also deposited thousands of
sequences in public databases for all of
the work we've done in addition to the
viruses that we've looked at here on
this timeline we've also started doing
work in the public health area where
we've collaborated with countries doing
zero surveys to be able to identify how
prevalent these viruses are in their
communities and have targeted services
to engage and potentially treat or
prevent new infections so this includes
uh partnering with the Georgian hcv
elimination program which we started
doing in 2015 and then 16 and 17 we were
working with the Democratic Republic of
Congo to look at the prevalence of Hep B
and C and more recently we've also
started doing a hepatitis B elimination
program in Pakistan where our we're
working with our partners to understand
the prevalence and identify patients who
need treatment
so along the way we've also
discovered new viruses and these are
diverse strains of the viruses that
we've been studying so in 2011 we found
the second known case of HIV group P
which is a very diverse strain it was
one of the farthest one out on that
phylogenetic tree I showed and to date
there's only two cases that have ever
been identified but what's important is
that we were able to detect this with
our tests before we knew it existed and
that speaks to how we've been keeping
mindful of viral diversity as we design
our tests at Abbott
further down the timeline we've also
found rare strains in Cameroon and the
Congo and characterized those over the
years but something that we saw in 2015
really stands out and that's when we
identified a new virus in addition to
the known viruses we're looking for
we're also continuously looking for new
pathogens that might present a threat
and so in 2015 when we found a new virus
we developed prototype diagnostic tests
to try and understand the potential
impact of that virus we didn't see any
cause for alarm it's not the next
pandemic but it taught us a lot about
how we can move quickly to respond to
new viruses that are emerging and so
collectively all the work we've done in
the program has led us to the fast
response we had in 2020 where we
developed over seven different assays to
SARS Cove 2 in a matter of months
in mind we've now continued our work to
understand new pathogens as we launch
the Abbott pandemic defense coalition
so we're always under the risk for a
potential new pandemic threat and that
is caused by a couple of different
components shown here the first is the
risk of known pathogens so things we
already know about that continuously
re-emerge from time to time in outbreaks
but the second ours is the viruses and
other pathogens that we don't know about
yet so those could be causing illnesses
that never get diagnosed and that
accounts for a pretty significant number
of cases in these disease States shown
here so if we knew what was causing
those illnesses we would be able to
better Define and meet the needs of
these patients but as they go
undiagnosed there's a potential that
something could be circulating that we
don't know about yet that could cause a
new pandemic and so that's where the
Coalition comes in to try and make a
difference
so if you look at our map here and
um you can see that we have 20 different
partners on five continents that are
doing the work in the program and I'll
show a little bit more about them in a
little bit but what makes this program
unique is that we have sites that are
very strong at being able to recognize
cases that could potentially be a new
pandemic so there's access and
geographical locations to Patient
samples where there might be an a higher
risk for new illnesses to emerge whether
that's because there's close proximity
to reservoirs of animals or vectors
where new viruses or other pathogens
could cross over into the human
population or because of the
geographical location where there's a a
lot of people coming together from
different places in one location and
that always allows pathogens to spread
as they come along with the people who
are traveling
all of these sites have excellent
technical capabilities to be able to do
the work of the program and identify new
pathogens
and so the program works by first
identifying what's in a sample so we
have clinicians around the world who are
looking for cases where they've come in
sick and the person has tested negative
for usual pathogens that would cause
that illness
um so we are able to then do sequencing
on those samples to identify if there's
something new and that takes a lot of
sophisticated bioinformatics to be able
to identify what's new in a sample but
once we find a new virus and what really
sets our program apart is that we can go
on to the next step in the development
phase where we can develop research use
tests that are molecular serology or
rapid Diagnostics that we can then
deploy to all of our sites especially
the one where the first case had been
seen so that we can start to do initial
research to understand how far something
has spread in a surveillance study and
those same kinds of scenarios we can
learn a lot about a path early on and
that information that we learn because
we can identify positive cases is what
we can use to help Public Health
communities to take appropriate measures
and make decisions that will protect
people
so in the end that's how we hope to see
the Coalition making a difference and
we're off to a good start if you look at
our track record so far we have 36
Publications and you can find more
information about those on the website I
won't elaborate them on this webinar but
I I invite you to take a look we also
have more information about our program
in some episodes that have aired online
at abbott-discovery.com the show in
depth how some of the partner sites are
working
in particular there's one that
highlights the work that my colleague Dr
Olivera will be sharing in the next part
of this webinar and then we've also been
featured recently in Time Magazine and
showcase the work we've done over the
course of the program
because what our map looks like and you
can see where all of these sites are
located as part of the Coalition
we have seven sites in Africa and one in
South Africa that we'll be highlighting
today is the work done by Dr Olivera and
his team here at sarri and so with that
I'd like to hand over the presentation
to Dr Olivera
welcome Julio yes yes yes thank you very
much and it's a great pleasure to be
here with with Abbot today
as we speak from you we just launch uh
here in South Africa the biggest
investment on biomedical research
Innovation open this week yeah is a
state of the art
um facility based in Cape Town that it
it really have some of the most advanced
um
methods the second adjusting your
computer so what we thought that would
be great to also do here in this week
given that we are launching the the
largest genomics facility in Africa to
also with some collaborators highlight
another program that we have been that
we that we are launched yeah and that is
a program that affects all of us yeah
it's something that's going to be really
happening all around the world yeah it's
basic how climate change is shaping the
future of epidemics and the global
initiative that we are launching called
climate that's mean climate Amplified
diseases and epidemics This Global
initiative has many partners we have
over a hundred scientists collaborating
in those of locations across the globe
and that also involves collaboration
with foundations such as the Rockefeller
Foundation but also with companies like
Abbot to make sure that we can detect it
quick new epidemics as it emerge
especially caused by climate change so
my just to start my presentation I think
that's quite clear yeah the water have
really been abusing the environment yeah
and I'm just gonna show three photos of
a very impressive photographer that show
the effect of climate change in the
world yeah so not only we are completely
abusing fossil fears yeah we are really
polluting the the Earth yeah and that is
causing major effects it's in cause
effects on the environment on climate
change we are losing big environment
both at forests at the Arctic at
Antarctic and that create a problem to
humanity we're starting being much
closer contacts with animals that we
would be from different efforts yeah and
what it's called as we degrade the
environment we increase our also the
extreme events and I don't have to say
how many extreme events we had recently
of floods of big fires of storms of
droughts let's begin to feel large
epidemics yeah not fairly epidemic but
also feeling diseases and feeling
sometime this in a direct or indirect
way so for example one thing that's also
feeling that is what we call climate
migrants yeah it's when some people that
are affected by a climate come a little
sometimes a simple things as losing a
harvest yeah they have to migrate to
towns and they go living very poor
condition which really can also help the
spread of diseases yeah
but one thing that we have done in South
Africa and Africa and with Partners
around the world we really learn how to
respond to epidemics we learn how to do
science in real time and also having
access to sometimes the best technology
where people do not even expect if you
walk today in our building that we
launched this week yeah it is really off
the level of the top Laboratories in the
world and having access through very
automated Diagnostics so we can respond
in real time one good example was the
road that South Africa and the center
that I direct sorry had on
identification of many variants yeah and
the most extreme variants such as
Omicron and how we could do that in
hours not in days or weeks really
highlighting the previous experience of
generate epidemics when coupled with
high-tech knowledge can really help to
respond to epidemic in real time
and what we are talking here
unfortunately is not a small problem
yeah a very important review was
published in nature climate change
middle end of last year highlighting
that around 60 percent of all pathogens
in the world will be Amplified by by
climate change and here we are talking
many different kind of pathogens just to
ground you in this graphic on the
extreme left I have the climate events
yes such as warming precipitation floods
throughout Stone on the middle of the
graph I have the way that pathogens are
transmitted for example Vector Bond or
waterborne and on the right I have the
specific pathogen so one thing that we
know is that viruses is going to be
getting more normal and they're going to
be increasing transmission by Vector
bonds such as mosquitoes such as sticks
yeah but they also going to increase
transmission by waterborne and Airborne
as we just go through a pandemic
so if you get the details about viruses
yeah we are talking about just getting a
closer detail on that graphic yeah we
are talking if you just get a look on
virus transmitted by mosquitoes yeah
that's gonna be Amplified yeah we have
on the on the middle of the species of
mosquitoes yeah that's the ones that we
worry for example one of the one that we
are very worried is the service piece of
culax collects is a service piece of
mosquito that leave it cooler
temperature and high altitude which can
spread these diseases to many areas of
the world and that we are talking about
epidemics that had happened multiple
times in many countries in the world
which we have long experience on that so
we are talking about example Chikungunya
as we speak
today we release some results with
colleagues on on Brazil on the most
extreme Chikungunya outbreak in Paraguay
so we are talking about over a hundred
thousand cases we send a team to go help
the paraguayan government to sequence
and characterize that and that not only
100 000 case that was caused by a true
degrees increasing the temperature
followed by a high precipitation
mosquitoes and the highest outbreak ever
in Latin America with multiple deaths
that have never seen of this virus yeah
but you can we do not only affect Latin
America recent epidemics in Italy and
also entering North America we'll talk
about Dengue Dengue Fever that's
spreading we are talking about another
virus Rift Valley fever that has massive
pandemic potential last two years we
managed to work with colleagues in Kenya
to characterize and control our outbreak
of Rift Valley West Nile West Nile is
completely increasingly spread around
the world in the U.S you are having big
outbreaks West Niles and then we talk
about yellow fever zika or parasite like
malaria
Unfortunately they are all be Amplified
and it's going to be more common and
what we need to make sure is that they
do not evolve to be more pathogenic yeah
yeah on what what we are on what a virus
on water but we are talking about a lot
of affection of drinking water I don't
have to tell what a problem that is in
Durban recently we have a flood within
massive outbreak of E coli as we speak
following floods in Malawi we have the
biggest color outbreak in the African
continent and we are talking about
cholera E coli laptopurals but we're
also talk about viruses such as
hepatitis virus that can infect the
water stream and cause outbreaks yeah
so that's the kind of pathogens that we
are fighting yeah and the way that we do
that
It Is by creating a global Consortium to
generate the knowledge to develop the
tools and interventions that we can not
only track but that we can predict and
control diseases and epidemics that
amplify the climate change and that's
the name of the Consortium climate it
means climate Amplified this is an
epidemics but we want to go away if step
forward not only to predict track and
control but really use that advance to
prevent the the spread of global
epidemics and pandemics if you can
detect this pathogens characterize have
Diagnostic and Therapeutics before they
spread further we can control outbreaks
to become epidemics and epidemics to
become pandemics
so where that should be done yeah it
should be done
especially in the global South why the
global salt because the globe of salt is
the region of the world that are
experimenting more severe climate change
events especially extreme and have a
long experience to deal with this this
pathogens I hope we have showed the
world how our experience to dealing with
epidemics could really help the the
identification of variants of control of
covet yeah but this is not just a global
South program it's a really a Global
Contract a program that brings together
a Consortium with Partners around the
globe that have a long-term experience
with climate Amplified epidemics and
pathogens and these Partners include
Public Health agencies we are talking
about the main Public Health agents in
the world the African City The Who and
and and its Associated agents yeah
academic organizations such as ours
Public Health not a
Institute and also funders and Industry
we find very important that this program
is also done with industry because they
are the ones that are more likely to
develop the diagnostic Therapeutics and
and pandemics and vaccines yeah so what
we do this construction focus in three
main areas yeah it's focused on the
three areas to Simplicity name with a
college understand ecological access
using very big data as we are doing now
of of climate change of temperature of
of precipitation to try to really start
tracking when and where epidemics are
like to emerge advancing epidemiology we
are talking about also Big Data analysis
that involve Mobility data from cell
phone data yeah flight data calculating
the risk of importation of a pathogen
that when you link that together with
the susceptibility you can start guiding
where to sample and when in space on
time and really our effect on
evolutionary analysis of pathogens so we
have methods that can sequence any
pathogen the world metagenomics methods
and Target and we have to look because
what we saw with sasko V2 pathogens can
evolve to be more transmissible to
escape vaccines and to escape diagonals
so it's an race and that's where we
bring these three expertise together
which programs we are we are staffed
here we divide that program in different
geographic regions in the world we have
a program in climate Africa climate
America climate Asia Europe and Oceania
I just gonna give example how three of
the programs come together to try to
identify and characterize epidemics in
Africa despite in heavy Regional
programs we collaborate with them using
the expertise so for example in this
initial program that I'm going to show
you we use a lot of the methods that
have been developed in the American
special Latin Americans through
traceable viruses this means epidemics
caused by virus and mosquitoes such as
zika Dengue Chikungunya yellow fever how
to transfer that with Africa and with
American European collaborators how to
use the big data to Fast Track that yeah
so for example the the program has begun
in Africa by mapping the analysis of
Apple viral data producing genomic data
and training African Laboratories to
diagonals and sequence pathogens yeah
the first activity already has started
redhead results that's modeling
mathematical analysis of these use
susceptibility and in Africa and review
all the activities that have been done
yeah then we have offered area providing
rapid genomic sequencing for any of
dozens of virus that are transmitted by
different vectors yeah through any
African country so they can send the
sample to us we will sequence them for
free as we have done for 26 African
countries during the covet pandemic but
they can also request support where we
give them protocols and many times and
teams and Diagnostics and reagents to be
sequenced in that area and then together
to determine what we should be focused
we find that's very important that
regions in the audience encountered
local scientific divide what is what
should be done yeah so this program
built a very successful program that we
had with African scientists yeah during
the pandemic we LED all the analysis of
the coveted data in Africa country we
are talking about collaborating with
hundreds of scientists our last
scientific paper are less results that
come in science one of the top
scientific genre have 300 African
collaborators yeah and not only
collaborated but leading the process
yeah so that's what we are doing in
Africa we are doing we are basic
answering a few big questions yeah
a few big questions there yeah
when and where these epidemics are
emerging yeah what and how they are much
what we know from previous data yeah and
then to analyze all this data to really
develop where we should be doing it's a
program that happened we meet every week
with hundreds of African collaborators
as I speak here to you now we have
brought it collaborators on 25 African
counters to our lab to be trained on how
to sequence these pathogens in the
country
and we do that following what has been
constructed during the pandemic a very
effective system of Laboratories in
Africa which we've been a specialized
genomics facility of the Africa Citizen
and the who we can offer the support for
the African countries and very important
we do that also with industry both
Illumina provide reagents and with Abbot
providing Diagnostics so we can make
sure that we can identify these
pathogens in the different African
countries yeah
yeah
so in addition to that what we do is our
very long
and very impactful program of capacity
development yeah so what we did it is
really transfer programs to very large
groups both canalized data for example
and in August last year we ran a very
large program in South Africa in Senegal
and in Panama where we train people on
how to do that as we speak now this week
we have the large training program for
25 African countries ending August this
year we are bringing to Africa the
highest and most advanced virus
Evolution and molecular epidemiology
Workshop of him Workshop really to make
sure that we can not only generate but
analyze the data in the continent yeah
just just to summarize and to conclude
yeah over half of the non-pathogens in
the world are expected to increase due
to global warming yeah Brazil and Latin
America have Expo EX
large large multiple co-parent upper
viral epidemics such as Dengue and
yellow fever we have worked with them we
have seen many times deep in the grounds
here to characterize this epidemics we
have learned a lot from that process the
predictions that Africa may be the next
big place will be affected by these
outbreaks yeah and it is of global
interest that both this program that
identify this new emergency virus and
bacteria Latin America in Africa and
Asia is done as quick as possible
because this as we know climate change
keep Advanced and the same epidemics
will be hitting very soon Europe and not
not America become hot spots so how we
call this program is basic a health
insurance for the world if you can
quickly identify the pathogens and
characterize we can really help the
whole world that when that start growing
you have the diagnostic the Therapeutics
of the vaccines and that's what we do
based on the need to increase
surveillance and attack and respond to
outbreak and epidemics and that's why we
find so important to partner with
Partners like about for that process so
thank you very much and here we
officially launched the the climate
program
thanks Julio
uh for presenting climate and
oh
probably lose the
sorry about that okay so um I'd like to
thank Tulio for sharing the great work
you've done with your team and
um we really are glad to be working with
you as part of the Coalition so
um
after seeing all of the potential impact
that climate change can change can have
on infectious diseases
um there are things we can do today
especially you who are working in
clinical labs and so preparation really
is critical to a quick response
that means that the lab can really truly
play a critical role in protecting
communities during outbreaks as they
emerge
so that can look like a few different
things so first we should be familiar
with infectious diseases that are
impacted by climate change and all we've
seen some that Tulio has shared and I'll
go through some in a moment
secondly we can understand how your
hospital system can be preparing today
so that you can respond to new and
existing viral outbreaks and epidemics
because as we've seen the patterns of
infectious diseases will be changing as
climate changes
in particular there's a category of
pathogens that are impacted by changes
in precipitation so storms and floods
and water
um
causing the pattern for infectious
diseases like Hepatitis A and influenza
and the others listed here to become
closer to people in ways that they
haven't before so precipitation changes
have been shown to change the range of
where vectors and animals who carry
pathogens can live and thrive
and as climate changes Wildlife can come
closer to people as they forage for
limited resources and have different
habitats
and as there's more water there's also
more Wastewater overflow that can lead
to contaminated water sources and
foodborne illness can thrive
on the other hand
climate change can also bring people
closer to the pathogens and that can
happen when changes in precipitation
have already changed how people are
gathering and as Tulio Illustrated that
can also lead to migration of people in
response to being displaced by floods
and and other water related events in
caused by climate change
beyond the other Factor besides water
changes are also temperature changes so
that can be due to direct increases in
temperatures and also fires and drought
that can be secondary to those changes
in temperature and so there's a few
pathogens that are on both lists but
this list is slightly different we see
things like Dengue virus and and Chagas
and Crimean Congo hemorrhagic fever in
this list and so when these pathogens
come closer to people because of changes
in temperature it looks like Wildlife
changing where they can live and their
habitats are changed when they have to
move away
due to climate change and then warming
can also allow mosquitoes to thrive in
particular they can live in warmer
temperatures more easily and they can
actually have higher rates of biting and
have higher rates of viral replication
in the vector itself
we also know that warmer temperatures
bring people in closer contact with each
other and and alarmingly we also know
that melting of ice in the permafrost
can expose pathogens that we have not
seen in a long time in fact this has
been called Pandora's Box and so there's
potentially ancient pathogens that could
be re-released as we see melting Waters
due to higher temperatures
and so how does all of this impact what
you can do today
essentially building infrastructure to
screen out current epidemics can help
prepare for the outbreaks that could be
happening or new pathogens as a result
of climate change so that means that you
can start work working with ways to
combat existing epidemics and pandemics
that we're already dealing with today
because if we're able to respond to
those better we'll be able to make a
difference when new pathogens emerge so
opt out testing to screen for multiple
infectious diseases from a single
patient interaction and Sample can be a
good step forward
kinds of programs
um are going to actually be interacting
with people who are already accessing
the Health Care System including people
who could be difficult to reach
otherwise
it also eliminates the social stigma of
requesting a test so if people are all
getting tested it doesn't seem like
someone's singled out for just being
tested for one of these viruses
this can also reduce the cost of
inexpensive inpatient care if we're
catching infections sooner because
people are more broadly being tested
and then earlier diagnosed can diagnosis
can also obviously lead to better
engagement and care so that someone can
get the care that they need earlier in
their infection which improves outcomes
overall building these processes in
today can help protect the community in
the future not just with the current
pandemics but also to prepare for new
pathogens that could be emerging
for your particular lab could be how you
manage your workflows so this could be
ensuring that you have an emergency
response plan so that you're prepared if
the unthinkable happens as a new
pathogen enters your lab
you can also cross-train your staff so
that they're ready and prepared to
respond if needed and having the
flexibility to be able to use platforms
and cross-train can also allow you to
have people working wherever they're
needed most
you can also make sure that you're
prepared for changes in electricity in
case there's an emergency since that can
be a critical critical aspect of dealing
with an emergency related to climate
change
you can also prepare for Supply Chain
management and that could mean that
you're sure that your vendors can scale
up to accommodate needs that might
increase if there's an influx of cases
that need testing for a particular
pathogen that's impacted by climate
change
also adjust the way you manage your
inventory looking ahead as you might see
news coming about perhaps from Climate
about new pathogens that are likely to
spread in your area
you can also perform surveillance of
your Laboratory test results that could
mean that you're keeping an eye on what
tests are being ordered and if there's a
sudden spike in a particular pathogen
that people are asking to for test
results on and if those end up being
negative that could be an early alert
system that there could be a new
pathogen on the loose
and so with that I'd like to thank you
for
um listening to us today and I would
encourage any questions that you'd like
to ask
well thank you Dr Rogers and Professor
de Oliveira for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar and if you
have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's go ahead and take a look and
see how many questions
we've got we've got quite a few coming
in already
our first question
what kind of information can we learn
from viral sequences and why are they
important for clinical labs
so I'll start and I'm sure tuio could
add to this um because we've both been
working with a lot of sequences but in
particular the sequences from viruses
can be really important for clinical
Labs because as viruses mutate we need
to make sure that tests are continuing
to detect them and so if we're
monitoring sequences for Target regions
of tests we'll be able to ensure that
tests still work or alert that they
might not and we can correct that so
sequences can tell us a lot that would
impact diagnostic tests in clinical Labs
I'm sure truly would like to add to that
yes so so I agree with with Mary under
diagnose but can also tell you that
sequence can also identify how apathogen
is evolving so at the moment the our
biggest fear as evolutionary biologists
I work with virus Evolution yeah is that
the current strain of H5 and one that
circulating avian across the world
that's decimating the Asian species with
over 100 million deaths that may evolve
to become more pathogenic so we want to
have that information
especially if evolved to become human
transmitted we want to have that
information before that happened and
that's where we should be sequencing
this virus that's a good example other
way that's also quite important is
related to resistance to therapies for
example with HIV we want to know if not
only Diagnostics effective but if the
therapy will be effective because that
would be the objective of a laboratory
to guide a lot of time clinicians on the
effective therapy for HIV for TB for
cholera we want to know if the
antibiotics will work on the vaccine so
there is many utility is for knowing
that information for public health for
laboratory and for patients
thank you so much and our next question
for Professor de Oliveira why do you
this is actually a two-part question why
do you think culex does not receive as
much attention as it is and Anna fellas
and since Africa might be the upcoming
hot spot for the next Global pandemic
what are the chances of that pandemic
being caught by Rift Valley fever since
it is a viral noosis with a large
potential of outbreaks
okay thank you yeah thanks for that
question that's a very precise question
yeah so we I do agree I believe that of
course we have been very focused on
understanding the other two uh
subspecies of mosquitoes the ayats and
anopheles so that's the one that that
that caused a lot of the outbreak of the
other Arbor virus but collects is the
one that we worry and we worry also for
some of the virus adaptation from a
species of mosquitoes getting adapted to
the other one Rift Valley has a has a
pandemic potential it's something that
we are very aware any warning so for
example last year there was a warning of
a potential Rift Valley outbreak in
South Africa the warning it came from
basic data analyzing both a mosquito
concentrations temperature and water
we were quite prepared we have sequence
from that and that warning was a false
warning we didn't have any outbreak of
Rift Valley in South Africa but the year
before we had one in Kenya which we also
have a team that collaborates there with
our colleague at the Hillary and we
could classify and sequence The Rift
Valley fever to see if it's evolving to
be more transmissible so that is a virus
that is in our radar and we know that as
global warming increases that's going to
be more warnings of potential outbreaks
of Rift Valley fever and that's why we
have to have a system to predict and
detect very quick to make sure that
before it's starting uh to become
epidemic that we have not only the
diagnostic but the Therapeutics and
vaccines for such a threat
thank you so much Professor de Oliveira
our next question from our audience and
I want to thank again our audience for
these great questions coming in how does
this impact people living in North
America or people outside Africa or the
South
well I would say I know living in North
America myself that we have floods and
hurricanes and a lot of natural
disasters where these kinds of pathogens
can Thrive and we're certainly not
immune to the effects of climate change
with changes in pattern of
um the range where specific species of
mosquitoes can live so I don't really
think this is limited to impacting the
global South I think this impacts
everyone
yes yes I completely agree and and
especially if you just go a little bit
back in time yeah very recently with the
covet pandemic yeah you will remember
how unprepared was not America it was
Europe for that despite multiple
warnings yeah so we need to be prepared
yeah so some of the pathogens that is
very direct implication one thing that
we learn when we detect the Omicron
variant is that the virus and pathogens
they do not respect borders they travel
in Planes they're traveling Birds they
travel in containers of ships so it's
quite clear that large introductions
could happen in America yeah and that
could feel outbreak and in Europe so
that's why it's of interest of America
North America and Europe to investing
such program because would it be much
safe that you have detect this pathogen
as they emerge yeah before they are
being introduced and causing large
outbreaks yeah at the moment we know
some of them that's already causing
large outbreaks in America for example
West Nile in Florida
zika in Florida recently we know that
also it floods you can have bacteria
that the same way that you have cholera
here wouldn't be impossible to also have
color outbreaks in America so that's why
we went to a global program yeah that
could provide basic early warning and
and characterization really what we
believe that would be a health insurance
for the world and I really believe that
both Europe and North America should
invest in that program so we already
have big big investors such as a
Rockefeller Foundation the Abbot and
other companies and funders that are
seeing the importance of quick
characterize a virus and bacteria where
they emerge before they become a global
program
well thank you both very much our next
question coming in and we have time for
a few more what kind of data will be
used to predict climate Amplified
infectious diseases
yeah okay yes so so what kind of data
it's used we we have two main sources of
data yeah one is what we call ecological
data and that is for example a data
related to temperature yeah in a given
location data related to precipitation
Rings yeah early warning of floods
coming yeah of high uh Cyclone so this
is data that we currently use very well
to forecast climate events yeah so that
that's really important data to us to to
to to start linking to that in addition
to that we have something that's called
sometimes intermediate hosts yeah the
presence of a given mosquito or a tick
or maybe a bacteria in the water so we
start linking this data of climate with
presence of amplifying Agents and then
you add the next big layer of data
that's data related to Mobility yeah
flight data cargo data where is likely
to be introduced in what we call that
the risk of importation yeah yeah
animals such as Birds flight Roots so
imagine if you have an outbreak of
pathogen X that can be transmitted in
birds and you have a direct flight route
between that area to where you are that
should start to ringing bells and that's
what the kind of thing that climate does
most a big part of climate is not
laboratory it's data scientists that
have access to very large computer
clusters that can start at linking and
cross-checking data that can start in
highlighting where epidemics may happen
through very simple case the very
explosive epidemic of chikungunya
associated with increase of 2 degrees
last year high range and high mosquito
population the floods that had in
Pakistan that feel a cholera and Dengue
yeah the floods that happen in Malawi
that feel the largest
cholera epidemic ever seen in Africa so
that's the kind of data that we want to
be using real time to predict and then
we want to have the Diagnostics and the
way to respond in the right place before
it happens
thank you so much now are there recent
examples of climate change impacting
infectious diseases
yes I can give like
50 examples okay but but but but I don't
want to overwhelm everyone so so we have
for example uh Resurgence for example
when direct climate change such as
cholera such as Chikungunya such as
Dengue such as yellow fever such as zika
such as Rift Valley so that's when you
have higher number or a warmer weather
more rain and more vector and we are
talking about six pathogens that cause
some of the large wood outbreaks in the
last few years Latin America
southeast Asia and Africa and then we
also have the the ones that when you
disturb the environment yeah and we
start destroying the environment that
animals are getting much closer
proximate to it with men we talk about
saskovichu we are talking about
influenza yeah we are talking about many
different pathogens that would live
naturally in the animals but when the
habitats are Disturbed they get much
closer proximity with with humans you
have the ones that Amplified by water we
have back cases of Hepatitis E with a
terrible virus that we haven't seen how
to break for decades and that with very
poor sanitation in some refugee camps or
other areas yeah and we have cholera you
have E coli but I I that's normally
Amplified by climate events and high
rains and floods I hope I could give you
a few examples we'll talk about
respiratory Vector born and waterborne
pathogens here
thank you so much now how does
climate change impacts something like
HIV or hepatitis
this is like hepatitis A or Hepatitis E
and so whenever there's contamination of
water sources with Wastewater due to
flooding that's when you can start get
contamination that makes people sick but
of course Hepatitis B C and HIV have a
different method of transmission and
that can change when people are closer
together and and surrounded in new
surroundings and and whenever you have
migration of people you have migration
of those viruses too so there's always
that potential as climate change affects
where people live that you can have
changes in all of those viruses
absolutely it looks like we have a time
for just a couple more how did climate
change affect the spread of Japanese
Encephalitis in the Asian part of the
world
yes yes thank you that that that's
that's a very important question for
example we know that Japanese
encephalites is happen more common for
example in Australia yeah Australia and
the University of Sydney and the
Australia public health government is a
big part of the of the climate program
and the leading scientists there is
Professor Edward Holmes yeah so what
they highlight they highlighted that
again another mosquito
outbreak that can be Amplified yeah so
Australia unfortunately may be one of
the first developed countries yeah
that's
for a severe climate epidemics because
they are in that area of the global
South yeah and that's why they are
investing also big the all the top
scientists many of the top scientists in
the country and the institutions in this
program yeah
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
what surprises can be anticipated from
the melting of the permafrost
well there could be a lot of surprises
there I mean these would be pathogens
that have been extinct for thousands and
thousands of years and so unless we
actually go digging in the permafrost to
sequence them it would be hard to know
so I don't know Julio if you've seen any
data like that before yes I think the
one that that scientists were the most
with the different pox and smallpox that
would have to be frozen for years and
re-emerge yeah but another thing just to
highlight is not always just something
that exists and re-emerge but as you
start losing
um ice caps and forests you have animals
that would be living in more far away
from the human populations coming closer
and a lot of times many pathogens that
we don't even know because we didn't
have contact with the wildlife and
that's that's what I worry the most is
not the ones that we know but that's
their ones that we do not know such as
it happened with the saskovicho pandemic
recently
well Professor Dale Avera and Dr Rogers
thank you so much for your presentation
today would you like to provide any
final comments for our audience before
we go
my final comments is that
we that
if epidemics happen in one part of the
world they can easily happen in the
other part of the world
so and that's why we have to work as a
global program
yeah this thing should believe that like
that's a problem that will not affect me
my country unfortunately is not what we
have seen with the covet pandemics is
not what we are seeing with many spread
of pathogens to Regions geographic
regions that we have not seen and we are
unfortunately entering as we destroy the
environment and climate change on the
age of epidemics I know that no one
wanna hear about that after we finish a
pandemic yeah but we also
doesn't mean that we have to enter in
the age of the pandemics and that's why
this kind of program to allow the
highest level technology and support to
detect pathogens where they may emerge
which we don't know where it is in the
world is so important so that we can
have the tools to control epidemic
before become a pandemic yeah thank you
yeah and I would add that we're in a
position to be able to deal with these
new pathogens and so there are things
that we can do to prepare so that we
respond and avoid an epidemic from
becoming a pandemic like Tulio said
because if we work together we can
actually apply those tools and make a
difference we don't have to let this get
out of hand if we work together and
that's what I'd encourage anyone
listening to do
well I want to thank you both again for
your time today and for such important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abbott for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone be safe
bye-bye
take care